buenas noches
tal vez a usted les gustaría que yo
llegara aquí con una receta o con una
bolsita llena pastillita así que les
diga
tómese esto para que alcance sus
objetivos tómese esto para que logre sus
metas pero no en mi caso 18 años
consecutivos en deportes de contacto con
excelentes resultados en youtube en
sambo en mma donde más con golpe más que
un derribe más que una sumisión más que
hacer sonar el himno nacional o de un
dial la bandera de costa rica en el
extranjero que es lo que las personas
ven cada vez que yo compito todos ven el
resultado pero nadie ve el proceso pero
la verdad es que detrás de todo esto hay
mucho trabajo entrega disciplina
constancia hay retos fuerza de voluntad
hay miedos hay errores hay fracasos hay
obstáculos mi hermano siempre me ha
dicho reina es que usted nació con
estrellita pero de dónde nace esa
estrellita primero he tenido que vencer
muchos obstáculos
el primero es ser mujer en una
machista crecí escuchando frases como el
hombre fuerte la mujer es débil
el hombre trabaja la mujer está en la
casa los niños no lloran y si un niño
lloraba le decían que era una mujercita
porque yo era era sinónimo de debilidad
por dicha todo estudio cambiando con el
tiempo christina un lugar tradicional de
escasos recursos donde vivo pas
carpintero mi mamá es ama de casa seis
hijos donde como lo manda la sociedad y
papá es un padre proveedor y a mi mamá
le toca la educación y la crianza de
nosotros ella paso por tantas cosas para
hacernos salir adelante que lo que puedo
decir en resumen es que mi mamá es una
gran luchadora
ella nos decía una frase estudien para
que tengan un buen trabajo y lleguen a
ser alguien en la vida y esa frase a mí
me marcó y yo de verdad quería llegar a
ser alguien en la vida quería ser
diferente por diferentes situaciones que
viví de niña donde tuve agresiones
físicas agresiones verbales y rechazos
llegué a pensar que las mujeres veníamos
a este mundo a sufrir y que de verdad la
sociedad tenía razón llorar era una
debilidad cuando me pasaba algo lo que
hacía era que me esperaba que llegara la
noche para llorar a escondidas donde
nadie me viera porque yo quería ser
diferente y para ser diferente primero
tenía que ser fuerte a los 17 años me
gradué la secundaria y lo primero que me
dice mi papá es reina hasta aquí le
ayudo yo tiene que empezar a trabajar
dar plata a la casa y si quiere estudiar
lo tiene que hacer por sus propios
medios empecé a trabajar y
simultáneamente a esto me metí a un
equipo de atletismo toda la vida me han
gustado los deportes y mi hermano mayor
hacía atletismo así que tenía un buen
ejemplo para seguir
aquí es donde empiezo a ganar la
disciplina que es uno de los puntos más
importantes para alcanzar cualquier
objetivo que nos propongamos en la vida
los días de pista los trabajábamos
detrás de la iglesia de la abuelita en
una cuadra que hay ahí
cuando yo salía de la casa hacia el
trabajo iba dispuesta a entrenar en la
noche pero cuando ya venía el trabajo
venía cansada me subía el bus venía
cabeceando me venía durmiendo llegaba al
parque a las bolitas y no me bajaba
seguía directo para la casa ya estando
en la casa me entraba un sentimiento de
culpa y yo me empezaba a tratar mal
entonces opté por venirme en un bus que
pasara por el parque a la abuelita pero
que no siguiera hacia mi casa
obligatoriamente por más cansada que yo
viniera me tenía que bajar y ya estando
ahí iba a entrenar al año de estar
trabajando decidido estudiar quería
estudiar educación física y una y una
universidad había abierto la carrera
para las personas que trabajaban
entonces las clases eran los viernes por
la noche y los sábados en el día fue un
éxito así puede estudiar a los 21 casi
22 años inicio los deportes de contacto
y fue por insistencia de un compañero a
la universidad sin mentir les duró dos
años insistiendo en que me metiera a ser
judo él decía que yo iba a ser buena
un día le dije sabe que ya me tiene tan
cansada que voy a ir a ver qué es esa
cochinada
llegué al grupo el sensei walter wise a
que ha sido mi entrenador durante estos
18 años
la clase fue tan dura tan dura
qué
eso fue lo que me gustó
tenía tantos años tenía cinco años
estaba haciendo atletismo y no entendía
por qué el cuerpo ahora me dolía tanto
no había sentido ese dolor él dice que
él me dio físicamente y que no daba ni
un cinco por mí que creyó que ni
siquiera una clase la iba a aguantar
algo tuvo que haber visto en mí no sé
tal vez el que no me rindiera de sus
clases porque un día me dice reina siga
llegando una hora antes a los
entrenamientos para que entrena
solamente conmigo y suba más rápido su
nivel así lo hicimos durante mucho
tiempo a los dos meses de haber empezado
a entrenar con el millón torneo y lo
gane le gané a muchachos que tienen más
de cuatro y seis años de estar
entrenando seguíamos entrenando seguimos
compitiendo seguíamos ganando ganaba mi
categoría ganaba la categoría libre
ganaba la categoría de cintas superiores
me comprometí con esto empecé a soñar
con representar a costa rica en
campeonatos internacionales
teníamos un sensei que literalmente era
un sargento las clases eran matadoras
cuando nos veía vacilar en la clase
nos castigaba con ejercicios el mismo
que nos daba charlas de motivación y de
superación todas las noches que cuando
no podíamos más nos gritaba espíritu
espíritu el que no veía género sus
alumnos sino personas capaces de lograr
lo que se propongan en la vida nos llega
la oportunidad que estamos esperando
unas eliminatorias para ir a un centro
americano en el 2003 en guatemala de
nuestro grupo
ganamos varias categorías femeninas eso
hace que el sensei sea nombrado el
entrenador de la selección femenina sin
recibir ninguna remuneración a cambio
solamente para que no siguiera
entrenando ganó mi categoría pero los
directivos de la federación de judo le
dicen al sensei que yo estoy muy vieja
para representar al país que además soy
muy nueva en el deporte que debería
darle la oportunidad a personas más
jóvenes y que eran más técnicas que yo
el senséi pelea dice que dar le importa
y que además los resultados en el tatami
son los que hablan yo había ganado la
eliminatoria tenía el derecho de ir acá
nos damos cuenta que tenemos el tiempo
en contra el tiempo es uno de los
obstáculos más grandes que nos podemos
encontrar para alcanzar cualquier
objetivo porque el tiempo corre el
tiempo no se detiene el tiempo no se
recupera los demás países de
centroamérica llevan años de preparación
nosotros solamente llevábamos unos meses
la opción que encontramos fue trabajar
horas extras entrenamos hasta los
domingos
descansa vamos pero yo quería demostrar
que podía que la edad es solamente un
número y que si me preparo puedo lograr
lo que me proponga los moretones el
cansancio el dolor el sacrificio
empezaron a formar parte de mi vida mi
cuerpo no se acostumbra va pero yo me
decía que más del 50% del dolor está en
la mente y junto con el sacaba el coraje
que necesitaba para seguir adelante a
este coraje que no me permite rendirme
le llamo fuerza de voluntad
yo lo fui trabajando y fortaleciendo con
las situaciones que ha viviendo día a
día pero se dice que la fuerza de
voluntad es como un músculo que dice
trabaja se desarrolla se fortalece y
crece durante esta preparación tuve dos
lesiones de consideración la primera fue
la rodilla tuve un esguince grado 3 la
pierna se me iba de lado estoy en el
hospital y me dicen que me tienen que
ingresar llamar sensei me dice reina no
se niege e si se inglesa vamos a perder
todo el trabajo que llevamos hasta ahora
esa pierna la vamos a trabajar con
vendas con rodilleras y la vamos a
fortalecer además tiene el 99 por ciento
de su cuerpo bueno
así lo hicimos y luego viene mi segunda
lección que fue en el hombro estaba
compitiendo con compañeros tendieron
avanzado el cual ya me había tirado
varias veces yo no quería caer una vez
más y cuando iba para el suelo
nuevamente meto el brazo
sentí como se me reventaba el músculo
acá cuando me levantaron esta parte yo
no la tenía lo que tenía era que un
hueco en el cen se llegó me monto el
hombro y aún así no dejamos de entrenar
seguíamos teniendo el tiempo en contra
aprendí a hacer paradas de mano con una
mano aprendía a hacer entradas con una
mano íbamos a la pista a hacer trabajos
de velocidad me vendaban el brazo me lo
unían al cuerpo y tenía este brazo para
abrazar así a las vueltas en el tiempo
que me pedían cuando terminaba de correr
tenía tan recargado el brazo porque no
me corría la circulación que tres en
seis meses compañeros me quitaban
rápidamente las ventas
no teníamos tiempo para descansar de
todos los seleccionados yo era la que
estaba ahí todos los días los
entrenamientos eran tan duros que mis
compañeros buscaban cualquier excusa
para no ir
pero yo tenía un objetivo llega el
centroamericano empieza el equipo de
costa rica- competir pelea que hacían
pelea que perdían salían llorando y
entre ellos mismo se consolaban yo donde
había esa senda lo que es fue que me
aparté subí la gradería me senté la
grada más alta concentrarme en lo mío
porque yo no me había preparado para eso
ese año fui campeona centroamericana
escuchar el himno nacional de costa rica
en el extranjero y que sea usted el que
lo haga sonar no tiene precio no tengo
palabras para expresar lo que se siente
regresamos a costa rica nos seguimos
preparando porque viene el
centroamericano del 2004 que iba a ser
en honduras lecciones van y lecciones
vienen pero no descansa vamos no
parábamos llega el centroamericano al
2004 y me entra el miedo me entra la
duda empecé a pensar que no me había
preparado lo suficiente para el evento y
con esta mentalidad entré a competir lo
que gané fue medalla de bronce para mí
fue un gran fracaso el seguir estaba tan
enojado tan enojado que duró como dos
horas
regañando no es tal vez más esa noche no
dormí pasé llorando toda la noche al día
siguiente competimos por equipos y gane
todas mis competencias les gané a las
mismas muchachas con los que había
competido el día anterior me di cuenta
que si estaba preparada que el trabajo
que habíamos hecho si servía creo que
había pasado era que me había caído
mentalmente que la mente es muy poderosa
que tenía que creer en mí y me prometí
nunca más perder en la vida para
centroamérica no el 2005 que es en el
salvador ganó oro y ese año fui elegida
la mejor judoca del país para el
centroamericano al 2006 que fue en costa
rica teníamos un equipazo femenino
ganamos tres medallas de oro dos
medallas de plata gane plata en la
categoría libre ganamos por equipos y
nos dieron el trofeo por país en la rama
femenina nos seguimos preparando porque
viene un campeonato panamericano y no
sabemos a quién van a llevar pero que
podamos estar listos cuando nos dicen
que iban a mandar a uno de los muchachos
que había ganado medalla de bronce
cuando le 6 reclama porque los
resultados de nosotros eran mejor
lo que le dicen es que una medalla de
bronce masculina vale más que una de oro
femenina imagínense cómo nos sentíamos
al tiempo no llega una carta donde nos
dicen que es igual 3 ya no más el
entrenador de la selección femenina nos
pusieron a otra persona que ni siquiera
nos conocía obviamente peleamos por
nuestro entrenador teníamos 5 años de
trabajar con él él nos había formado y
lo que hicieron fue que nos echaron del
judo no nos dejaron competir más ni
siquiera a nivel nacional y nos sacaron
del gimnasio la sabana que eran te
entrenábamos de todos mis compañeros yo
fue la única que seguía ellos se
cansaron de luchar y llenaron su judo
aquí empezamos a competir en jiu jitsu
nos empezó a ir súper bien luego aparece
el mma me invitan a competir a un torneo
a un evento yo no sé nada de artes
marciales mixtas me reúno con el sensei
me dice reinas y eso lo que usted quiere
yo la preparo empezamos a prepararnos
para el evento sinceramente cuando se me
venía encima con golpes y patadas nueva
tanto miedo que yo me queda hecho un
puñito en una esquina y les enseño
encima dándome
poco a poco fuimos venciendo ese miedo y
nos seguimos preparando seguíamos
teniendo el tiempo en contra cuando yo
llegué al gimnasio empezaba a subir las
gradas y ya sabía lo que iba
sinceramente me entraba un miedo que yo
me quería devolver pero tenía un
objetivo y el coraje que sentía era más
grande que ese miedo seguíamos
preparándonos aprender nuevas cosas las
técnicas de judo los transforme para
emea
al final el evento no se da pero
seguimos entrenando la primera pelea de
mma lago en el 2009 y la ganamos siguen
apareciendo peleas de mma y seguimos
ganando en el 2013 nace mi pequeño gran
guerrero raúl este enano me vino enseñar
que llorar no es una debilidad ha sacado
la parte sentimental que hay en mí y me
ha sacado lágrimas de felicidad durante
el embarazo no deje de entrenar a los 28
días de nacido retomó los entrenamientos
a los 8 meses de nacido
volvemos a la jaula y volvemos a ganar
actualmente en mma llevo 10 peleas
ganadas y una perdida por decisión
dividida en el 2014
de sambo costa rica- empezamos a
competir actualmente a nivel nacional no
he perdido ni una sola pelea en mi
categoría y en la categoría libre a
nivel internacional en estos cinco años
he sido dos veces subcampeona
panamericana tres veces campeona
panamericana campeona de juegos
centroamericanos campeona panamericana
de samba playa el último evento
importante lo hice ahora
el 4 de septiembre donde gane plata en
el campeonato mundial de artes marciales
ahorita estoy franca rankeada quinto
lugar a nivel mundial en mma la última
pelea le hice el 2 de agosto contra una
de las más fuertes exponentes a nivel
mundial soy la frausto donde nadie cree
en nosotros porque ella ha sido campeona
mundial de muay thai campeona de
bellator campeona strikeforce
donde hasta la doctora que nos pusieron
en la esquina nos decía en combate
américas no se tira la toalla si ustedes
se quieren rendir me dicen que yo para
la pelea dice el sensei que él contó las
veces que ella nos dijo esto que fueron
seis veces yo sinceramente no las conté
a pesar de que nadie querían nosotros
trabajamos fuerte creímos en nuestro
trabajo y ganamos a los dos minutos 32
segundos
todo esto lo hemos logrado venciendo los
obstáculos que se nos han presentado sin
buscar excusas trabajando duro durante
estos 18 años sin desviarnos del
objetivo el resumen les puedo decir que
no hay una pastillita ni receta que nos
ayude a alcanzar los objetivos
que tenemos que creer en nosotros que
cada vez que vayamos venciendo a cada
una de las trabas que se nos van
apareciendo vamos fortaleciendo nuestro
espíritu nuestra fuerza de voluntad
nuestro coraje la edad es solamente un
número el tiempo es nuestro enemigo no
podemos detenernos
tenemos que formar alianzas con personas
que nos ayuden a crecer y que nos den la
mano cuando nos vamos a levantar a caer
perdón
y terminó diciéndoles nuestro lema de
academia hay que estar listos para
cuando la oportunidad se presente no
esperar a que llegue la oportunidad para
empezar a prepararnos y si yo puedo
ustedes pueden gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]